alright guys i know the title with the
whole recession thing sounds crazy so
give me a chance to explain but
regardless of whether we're going into a
recession right now or not it's always a
good idea to be budgeting wherever you
can especially if you still love apple
products and want to stay in the
ecosystem while also saving some cash so
what i'll be doing in this video is
going through each category of apple
products and giving you guys some really
good tips and options to save a lot of
money but first i've gotta explain the
whole recession thing it's no secret
that inflation has been putting pressure
on regular people around the world with
prices of everything going higher and
higher including food gasoline
everyday products services cars
utilities rent housing and more and to
make things worse diesel prices have
recently been skyrocketing in the past
week which is putting a huge strain on
truckers who transport basically all of
our food and goods to the stores we buy
from which means that they have to pass
the extra cost along to other businesses
and consumers for example amazon just
announced a five percent fuel in
inflation surcharge for sellers which
means that they'll be raising the prices
of basically everything on amazon to
cover that extra cost and because of
that it seems like things could be
getting worse in the near future for
various reasons first of all other
countries are reporting even worse
inflation than us like over thirty
percent in the eurozone and is seventy
percent inflation in turkey yes seventy
percent on top of that the china
lockdowns are continuing which means
more supply shortages which will
continue to inflate prices even apple
recently reported their earnings and
mentioned that they could lose up to 8
billion
due to the china lockdowns the federal
reserve also just had their fomc meeting
where they said that there are further
risks to inflation due to the china
lockdowns which is one of the reasons
they raised interest rates by half a
percentage point the first time in 22
years that the rakes were hiked this
much and jerome powell says that they're
just getting started with the hikes with
more 50 basis point hikes on the table
for the next couple of meetings and
maybe even 75 basis points next month
and while we did have a huge rally in
the stock market as soon as jerome
announced the hike all of it and more
was lost the very next day because we
got the worst us productivity report
since
1947. and now to explain the
significance of the rate hikes it's
basically going to slow down the economy
because higher rates mean that it
becomes more expensive to borrow money
so anything purchased with a loan will
be getting more expensive and what this
basically leads to is lowered demand for
buying things including tech products
which apple analyst ming chi kuo has
already been seeing in terms of the
global smartphone market for months
which could lead to people getting laid
off from their jobs bringing us closer
to an official recession coming sooner
than expected in fact a recent cnbc poll
shows 80 of small businesses are
expecting to see a recession this year
which is why the small business sector
has laid off 105 000 total employees in
the first quarter of the year and it's
not just small businesses we are now
seeing reports of facebook and amazon
doing hiring freezes and even apple has
reportedly frozen hiring of genius bar
employees and the only reason it makes
sense for anyone to stop hiring is
because they expect sales to go down
this year potentially because of a
recession and whenever we start seeing
more and more news headlines of
recession risks that's when people start
saving money and budgeting which is
basically why i decided to make this
video and in terms of how close we are
to going into a recession we're actually
50 of the way there because the us
economy actually contracted or went
negative in the first quarter of 2022
compared to last year so if the second
quarter is also going to be negative
then we'll officially be in a recession
for the first half of this year and
according to jp morgan chase's ceo jamie
dimon he sees a 33 chance of a mild
recession and 33 chance of a severe
recession so that's a 66 chance of
recession according to the ceo of the
biggest bank of the us but of course we
might completely avoid a recession and
not have anything to worry about but
just in case you're thinking of ways to
save money on the apple ecosystem let's
get into some tips and great deals on
apple products first of all whatever
you're buying you should definitely be
buying it from amazon instead of apple's
website because apple never has sale
prices on their website compared to
amazon which routinely has some really
amazing deals as i'll show you over the
next few minutes getting started if
you're looking to upgrade your iphone
you can now find a fully unlocked
renewed iphone 12 for just 496 bucks
which is a killer deal because you have
up to 90 days to return it if you change
your mind and the iphone 12 features the
new flat sided redesign and one of my
favorite iphone features ever max safe
which i literally use every day for
charging mounting my iphone in my car
and for my mac safe wallet which is
really convenient and speaking of mac
save accessories instead of buying
apple's mac save charger for 39
and their 20 watt usb c power adapter
for 19
which is a total of 58 bucks you can
literally just buy anker's max safe
wireless charger that comes bundled with
a 20 watt adapter for only 22 bucks
right now if you're okay with 7.5 watt
charging speeds and instead of going on
apple's website to buy a mac safe car
vent mount for 40 to 60 bucks you should
be buying this one for 27 because it
comes bundled with everything you need
including the max a wireless charger the
power cable and the power adapter which
i personally use in both of my cars
because it's my all-time favorite iphone
accessory ever moving forward apple
sells an expensive 59 max safe wallet
but this one is only 24 bucks and it
features much stronger magnets compared
to the weak ones in apple's wallet which
is the number one complaint about it now
before i move on to the best ways to
save on max i want to mention that you
can buy a six foot anchor usb c to
lightning cable for only 15 bucks
instead of paying apple 29
for their 6 foot cable first of all if
you're thinking of buying a new mac i
fully believe that the m1 macbook air
for 950 bucks on amazon is by far the
best bang for the buck mac of all time
due to the m1 chip being more than
powerful enough for most people as well
as having absolutely insane battery life
and not having a fan that will lead to
dust clogging the inside of the macbook
which means that it's going to be
reliable for years and yes we are
expecting the redesigned m2 macbook air
later this year but it's also going to
come with a price increase likely
starting at 1200 so if you're trying to
save money you should honestly just buy
the m1 macbook air right now while it's
on sale and if you're looking for a more
powerful macbook i honestly believe that
the base 2 000 14 inch macbook pro is
more than fast enough for a lot of
people out there that use productivity
apps like photo editing music production
programming video editing and more but
let's say you already have the m1
macbook air and the main reason you want
to upgrade to the new macbook pro is
because of the extra ports i would
instead buy an anchor usbc hub for 60
bucks to get those extra ports instead
of buying a whole new macbook pro and in
my opinion one of the best ways to save
on macs is to save on the internal
storage cost so instead of paying apple
400. to upgrade your macbook air to one
terabyte of storage you can buy the
reliable samsung t5 one terabyte
external ssd for only a hundred bucks or
upgrade to the faster t7 model for just
fifteen dollars more now moving on to
the best ways to save on the ipad
ecosystem the current budget ipad is 20
bucks off which is a pretty good deal
because the storage space is now doubled
to 64 gigs with the new model making it
a very good deal and if you want a more
modern looking ipad you've of course got
the new ipad mini which is currently a
hundred dollars off right now but if
you're looking for a crazy good deal on
a 12.9 inch ipad pro here's a renewed
2018 model with the flat sided modern
redesign and 256 gigs of storage for
only
539 bucks which is probably the best
deal i've ever seen and in terms of
accessories instead of paying apple 100
or even 129 bucks for the apple pencil
you can buy the logitech crayon for only
61. right now which actually supports
almost every ipad including the ipad 9th
gen and the new ipad mini 6. and instead
of buying apple's expensive magic
keyboard for the ipad air and ipad pro
for 300
you can get the logitech folio touch for
the ipad air for only 145 bucks or the
ipad pro version for 160 bucks and both
of them support all of apple's unique
trackpad gestures just like the magic
keyboard thanks to smart connector
support now in terms of airpods you can
now get a basic set of 2nd gen airpods
for only 100
which is the best price ever or if you
want the earpods pros they're only 175
right now which is a great deal because
they're much better than the new airpods
3. now moving on to the apple watch
amazon currently has some of the best
sales right now including a brand new
apple watch se for only 229 dollars
which i think is the best one to buy if
you're on a budget because it comes with
almost all the best features for the
lowest possible price or if you really
want to get the best in class series
seven it's currently 70 off so only 329
bucks which is probably the best price
i've ever seen on a latest model and if
you think you have to buy apple's
expensive watch bands you don't there
are a ton of great options on amazon
that are much less expensive like this
one for 13 bucks which is rated very
well with positive reviews instead of
paying apple a hundred dollars for their
solo braided loop bands and there you
guys go those are a bunch of great apple
ecosystem deals and products to help you
save money especially if we are going
into a recession now if you completely
disagree with my thoughts then let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed the video click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]